dita
basically what you told us about the way
you survived was
putting yourself in this kingdom of
imagination
and telling yourself all the time i will
i will not die i will not die i will not
die i will survive this
how important is has been imagination
for the rest of your life
more practical person i'm
reproducting nature
i'm painting flowers and and trees and
leaves
and i i don't
feel very uh i don't think that there
is a much imagination in my
uh my work or in my thoughts
you gave me a beautiful painting of the
flowers you made for me yeah but they
are not the
imagination they are copies of nature
when you were were you in that when you
were in that terrible place were you
imagining
were you imagining you were somewhere
else i don't
remember i don't remember i remember
feelings and events but i don't think
imagination look we were so
on such a level of a basic
needs we wear
i'll make a it is a scale of them
terribly hungry terribly cold
no privacy never alone
never not even one day on the la tree
never never alone never
not no moment without being surrounded
by
other people
and interested in living whatever else
was looking at how people
became weaker and weakened and then died
like my father
i can't remember the what did what did
what we did do was speaking of food
imagining food that was that was very
popular
we're standing together and talking what
we used to have
for dinner yeah and how mother cooked
this and that
and the recipes after the war i must
remember what you
told me how do you make this and so
that was uh the topic yeah that's not
much
not much esoteric
things it was still the imagination but
it was imagination about something so
concrete i mean the the cooking was
food was on our mind all the day we were
that was
you were filled with craving for food